how do we come back from the political
brink you've got
blm torching the country and defending
kids stabbing other kids
just to own the cops calls for
abolishing the police
entirely and now the republican standard
bearer at least in
in california is a man who thinks that
he's a woman we have
really something has gone wrong in our
political world
do you know who has the answer one of
the few politicians with crossover
appeal in this country
tulsi gabbard who says hey guys chill
out
hang loose and just embrace the spirit
of aloha my dear friends my fellow
americans
please please let us stop the
racialization of
everyone and everything it's racialism
we are all children of god and are
therefore
family in the truest sense no matter our
race or ethnicity
this is aloha and this is what our
country and the world need
the mainstream propaganda media and
politicians they want us
to constantly focus on our skin color
and the skin color of others
because it helps them politically or
financially
aloha means respect and love
for others it's what enables us to see
beyond our skin color
and see the soul the person within
so let's do our best to cultivate this
aloha in
our hearts and see and treat others
through this prism of love
not through the prism of race and
ethnicity
please let us not allow ourselves to be
led down this
dark and divisive path of racialism
and hate love this absolutely brilliant
what most people are going to hear is
this sort of platitudinous thing about
you know it's just about aloha
just chill out and pop a coconut you
know and have a few drinks
it's cool man we're all we're all people
let's just sing kumbaya
that's not what she's saying she's got a
little bit of that because she's a
politician
but what she's saying is more specific
and more insightful
she says a lot of people
in this country who are in very powerful
positions
have a financial and political stake in
keeping us divided
especially on this fault line of race
she's saying that the establishment
which doesn't like her any more than
they like donald trump actually they're
in different political parties
but the liberal establishment the blob
the corporations at you know the
multinationals
the administrative state the sort of
permanent
government the big tech sector
all of these the things that all work in
tandem
don't like tulsi gabbard because she
contradicts their narrative
and she's saying those guys have a real
incentive
to keep you all divided up so they can
maintain
their grip on power it is
just like what amazon does for instance
when
various local amazon worker groups want
to unionize
you've seen some memos come out about
this amazon will always go in and find
ways to get them to hate each other
and they and it's not just amazon big
companies have been doing this for a
long time
they'll go in and figure out the fault
lines in the company among the workers
so that the workers don't unionize and
then once they get
all the workers to hate each other the
big corporation gets to maintain power
the left has has recognized this for a
long time and the right
for a long time especially when the
right was shilling for big corporations
refused to acknowledge it but this is
true this is just what this is a very
basic political strategy and it's
obviously what's happening right now
and it does account i think for a lot of
the focus on these physical
characteristics
notice what she says here she says we're
all children of god
we're told to think in a racial way
primarily but we're all children of god
what she's saying here as a matter of
philosophy
is we're told to think about the
physical
but actually we have something that
binds us at a metaphysical level
this is by the way why christians
regardless of their views on evolution
or the origins of mankind
the church has always insisted upon the
descent of the human race
from two parents regardless of how that
all came to be
human beings must descend from these two
parents it's called monogenism
because that that accounts for our human
dignity and our human solidarity
how we are made in the image of god we
all have this common link all the way
back
tulsi gabbard pointing that out really
really good stuff
beneath all of the lines you've heard
about how we should all get along
that key the propaganda media that's
what you've got to be
on your guard against people don't like
it people don't like
the messages that we're being told by
the establishment media right now
however they continue to do it hold up
do not go anywhere you need to stay here
not forever
just until you smash that button and you
like
and you subscribe and you make sure that
you never miss a video from us
because youtube some of you messaged me
about this yesterday
there's been some shenanigans with my
show okay and i'm not saying what
just some weird stuff irregularities
make sure that you are getting
notifications every single time see you
[Music]
next
[Music]
you